and by the way some of you guys are
watching this you're commenting your
message and saying hey you know I kind
of like what you got on let me show you
the back of this which is sick check
this out
okay dude that is so badass
uh anyways we're having a whole new
military gear that's coming out a lot
because being a a guy that I have a lot
of respect for our veterans thank you
for your service thank you and being the
Airman of the year in the entire Air
Force is coming out these but the whole
series is about to be launched where
green value Tim and future looks bright
hats but this is just a teaser the shirt
quality is amazing it's one of my
favorite quality shirts to wear if you
would like to sport one of these you're
a veteran or you love America or you
love our military or your support our
military uh I suggest you go get this
validation shirt on the front of it says
businesses War it's just the reality a
business Works get this new one this is
New Gear being dropped for the first
time here today
[Music]
[Applause]